[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
back to ngo 2.0 because we wanted to
introduce
2.0 thinking and practice to ngos
therefore we started off
with social media literacy training
we teach grassroots ngos in western and
central provinces
of china to learn how to use social
media to engage in participatory
thinking launch interactive advocacy
campaigns
increase the transparency of ngo
operation
design online crowdfunding projects and
learn human-centered design to create
solutions to the problems that ngos are
tackling
to date we have trained approximately 2
200
ngos and this is a part of
our curriculum we also created other
programs
for example we developed
a web 2.0 toolbox for
ngos and we also built a crowdsourced
philanthropy map over which more than 27
000
ngos have registered their project data
and organization data
we also run civic hackathons in
collaboration with
transnational i.t companies domestic
chinese
i.t companies software developer and
maker communities
and universities especially departments
of computer science and design
in universities we have worked with
ching hua university and the university
of science and technology of china
and the senior sign university etc
as ngo 2.0 evolved we have grown into
an organization with an expertise in
designing
social media for social good and tech
for good projects
in short we practice ict powered
activism
and in the process we have grown into a
nationwide for lack of a better word
super ngo working with grassroots and
youth
in 34 provinces and municipalities
so all those activities form part of my
regular practice
as a non-confrontational activist
so now let's take a look at the concept
of non-confrontationalism
non-confrontational activism is a
thematic
threat running through my new book the
other digital china
now during my 10-year long experience of
running ngo 2.0 i
encountered a variety of
puzzled responses from my colleagues and
friends in the u.s
they ask how could a foreign ngo
specialize in ict activism
survive at all in such an adverse
environment
like china this question
however is a false question because
first of all
ngo 2.0 is not an international ngo
from day one i make sure that we
set it up as a local chinese ngo
operated by a largely
indigenous chinese team we now have
seven full-time employees in china
so the challenges at the core of our
operation are not much different from
those faced by the other grassroots ngos
in china
so we should so the question we should
ask instead
is how have the chinese and jews fared
through the successive reigns of an
authoritarian regime
well to farewell and china requires a
different mindset and a different
strategy
which is learning the art of restraint
and following the centuries-old cultural
logic of finding the middle ground
whereby
mission is however difficult will get
accomplished
this for the chinese activists this
means producing social good
without throwing a street revolution or
confronting the state
openly and aggressively
during the past 10 years i was exposed
bit by bit to a gradually unfolding
captivating picture
of social media activism in china in
which multiple players
from diverse sectors are leveraging the
network effect of 2.0 to create
incremental change in china and this
book is devoted to the ict practices
emerging from china's social sector
called at a
specific particular historical moment
thanks
partly to the arrival of 2.0 technology
and cyber utopianism and partly to the
communist party's
alleged commitment to policies aimed at
energizing the weak social sector
now with this book i was trying to
answer
to ask the question what is the
ecosystem
of social media activism looking like in
china today in the old media environment
the major civic actors were ngos
but since 2009 after
social media had gone mainstream in
china
mike uh this old ecosystem has changed
because micro blogging brought in four
new groups
of social actors they are the free
agents corporate sector
software developer communities and maker
labs and
the university sector and ngo 2.0
designed projects that involve
participants from all those sectors
i should also note that the great
majority of social actors we collaborate
with
are chinese millennials and members of
the generation z
[Music]
all those social actors share a
commitment
to making incremental change rather than
throwing
a street revolution
and uh together those actors from
diverse sectors are building an
invisible coalition to bring incremental
change to chinese society
in spite of censorship if you want me to
choose a single sentence to describe
this book
it would be this is a book about the
gray zones
in china in the gray zones chinese
activists
practice non-contentious social actions
so let's take a deeper dive into this
keyword
non-confrontational activism and i
and and ask what kind of politics it
implies and how does the concept and
practice
of non-confrontationalism challenge the
mainstream western liberal thinking
about
activism chinese social actors are named
above
don't fit squarely into the profile of
activists
prescribed in the western liberal
tradition because
chinese change makers are walking around
obstacles rather than breaking through
them
and they navigate tactfully between what
is lawful
and what is illegitimate uh we're all
familiar with the western paradigm that
tend
to equate action with resistance and
social change with the street
revolutions and i think it is time that
non-confrontational activism is
conceptualized
fully documented with case studies so
that we can
put on the front burner a very important
question
which is the agency of activists
operating in authoritarian countries
now generally speaking activists
practicing non-confrontationalism
are anonymous because their actions
purposefully attract
no attention they stay on the margins of
history and they remain peripheral to
academic discussions about
social actions even though it prevails
in all autocratic
societies where activists
resort to other means of serving social
good
then openly rebelling and openly
critiquing
in my book i incorporated a chapter on
the critical literature revolving around
the concept
and practice of non-confrontationalism
here i want to
single out one such book james c
scott's weapons of the week everyday
forms of peasant resistance
james scott introduced the concept of
invisible agents and their quiet and
piecemeal tactics
he also gave credit to what he called
the practice of calculated conformity
he well james scott's peasants typically
avoid
a direct and dramatic confrontation with
the authorities
but instead of condemning the peasant
silence
as complicitous or devoid of politics
scott locates the sites of peasant
action
in micro inconspicuous everyday forms of
food dragging false compliance faint
ignorance and so on
and this book represents a significant
milestone in valorizing the powerless
as political agents
now when we turn to a country like china
or
other illiberal societies where open
resistance is an
exception rather than the norm we
as researchers are called upon to go
beyond
the dichotomous mode of thinking to
solve
a puzzle the puzzle is why are they
exploited in those countries
except their situation as a normal or
even as a justifiable part of social
order
are chinese people fatalistic
complicitous or paralyzed by fear and
cowardice so this question has been
sitting on a lot of people's mind
surely if the chinese government could
hire as many as 2 million
people to insert deceptive writings into
social media posts
shouldn't we have good reasons to
believe that chinese censorship has
penetrated
every corner of that society and that
the censors have manipulated the public
opinions effortlessly
well that is the conventional reading of
the muted consensus of chinese people
over maintaining the status quo
and that formulation relegates the
entire population of china
into the category of the brainwashed
in reality though we know that chinese
people have more choices than being
brainwashed
and becoming martyrs so what is missing
in the scholarly research on china is
the massive middle ground in which
conformity is often a self-conscious
strategy
and that it might be possible to think
of a continuum of situations
ranging from the free dialogue what
kabum has called
ideal speech situation or the public
sphere
all the way to the concentration camp so
what
is understudied in the china field is
that continuum of situations
or the middle ground or the gray zones
in which the chinese activists
navigate day in and day out quite
successfully
as we all knew that the favorite topic
the hottest topic
for digital china scholars in the west
is chinese censorship with this book i'm
taking a different path
if we want to understand the real
everyday china
it is imperative we go beyond the simple
dichotomy of white and black and turn
our gaze
toward the gray so all this may sound a
bit abstract
what did i mean when i say chinese
activists operate in the gray zones
so let's take ngos for example and
illustrate how
ngos in china function in a tightly
controlled social space
or we could ask a slightly different
question
what is the relationship between chinese
ngos and chinese state
the shorthand answer to that question is
ngos in china
are compelled are obliged to learn how
to navigate within
the state apparatus now if you want me
to choose
three adjectives to describe chinese
ngos
they would be semi-official somewhere
popular semi-autonomous
somehow officials refer to the ngos
navigating within the state structure
simon popular refers to the
self-identification
of glasses and geos sign my autonomy is
the concept i will explain
later there is a
chinese saying hey
uh you you're going to learn quite a few
chinese sayings tonight
uh the most invisible place is the spot
right underneath the light this the spot
this spot
which means no place is safer than the
place of danger
in other words under the surveillance of
the party state it is easier to carve
out breathing spaces within the state
structure within the plant space
then create them outside it
so here hence the chinese paradox
the closer the relationship of an ngo is
to the chinese state
the more autonomous the more autonomous
it would become now this may still sound
abstract so let me share with you
an anecdote in the late 1990s i started
a collaborative research project
with a professor at peking university
on popular media and popular culture in
china
we wanted to hold an international
conference in beijing
but finding a safe conference venue was
very difficult because
the word media in the conference title
is politically sensitive
in china we eventually overcame the
problem by holding our conference
at a state-owned and state-run hotel
we were able to do this because one of
our participants
had a personal relationship with the
hotel manager
so there was no surveillance no
questions asked and
the conference went on very smoothly so
this is a very good example that
illustrates what i meant by the safest
place
is the place of danger the most
invisible place is the spot
right underneath the light so those
habitually clinging on to the western
binary thinking and western binary
dichotomous paradigms will have
difficulties grasping
how chinese people navigate in the
seemingly
seamless web of political control
now i want to emphasize that all chinese
people
not just chinese activists have a have a
subtle mindset
they are very good at finding creative
ways
of walking around obstacles that's
this said ngos and liberal societies
tend to practice non-confrontational
activism by default
and it is imperative they make change
within the system
i'm going to give you a quote to further
unbundle this paradox
this is this quote was from anthony sage
he was the former chief
of ford foundation in beijing he now
teaches
at harvard's kennedy school so he said
chinese ngos voluntary subordination to
the existing state structure should be
viewed
not as a measure of expediency but a
strategic move to enhance their ability
to manipulate the official and
semi-official
institutions for their own advantage
which means making more impact on
society and gaining a louder voice in
policy making discussions than if they
were to remain
completely autonomous and i may add
a risk being crushed immediately by the
authorities if they create
the ngo outside of the state structure
so hearing lies the fundamental
difference
between western ngos and their chinese
counterpart
i want to take this opportunity to point
out another
level another set of difference between
western civil society and chinese civil
society
western civil society came into
existence as a result of the agitating
growth of the social
the chinese civil society could only be
born and flourished
as a result of the voluntary retreat of
the state from society and that
retreat of the state from society
of course has been a gradual and
measured
process there is no doubt
that the gray zones in china were much
bigger in size
under the hooding tower region than
under the current region
however i would say they will always be
agreeing for chinese activists
it will never disappear when the
politically sensitive issue areas
occur that may endanger an ngo the ngo's
will
and its ability to negotiate with the
local state
out of it out of the dilemma is critical
to
its survival in the q a i would be glad
to share with you more
examples or more strategies of how to
cope with
the sensors
so bearing non-confrontational ethos in
mind
let's move on to the examples of social
media activism
staged on weibo first a quick definition
of social media activism
it refers to social actions triggered
through peer-to-peer networking between
weak ties and furthermore those social
actions are mobilized
via viral communications to create
online support
communities at scale so i picked uh
five examples
the first example is called a shaved
head action
in the mid 2000s guangzhou based
activist pong yin hui
wrote a web blog calling for 1 000
netizens fellow netizens to shave their
heads
as a symbolic gesture to stop
the city's night illumination project on
the pearl river which would cost
the city taxpayers more than 150 million
yuan without much
justification paul yeah posted his
photos before and after the shave
and on weibo and in 20 hours
he attracted 4 000 retweets and
recruited more than 20 people
to follow him and shave their heads
including a young woman and a few
children so what does
shaving one's head have anything to do
with energy conservation
well pamiya we argued mockingly that a
thousand
shaved heads could generate enough
brightness
to light up at the pearl river and
render the
lavish city project unnecessary
so we know that every joke is a tiny
revolution
because it upsets the established order
and pongian cheeky weibo post went viral
precisely because
protests triggered by humor humor is an
is a potent form of
non-confrontationalism
so protests triggered by humor
camouflage the agitators and dumb
funding
the sensors under the pressure of
public outcry and media exposure the
city government
eventually trimmed down the original the
original budget
of knight illumination by four-fifths
which is quite a victory for pyongyang
my second example uh
deals with the thumbs up sister
now when pong you was made his protest
against the
city city's native illumination project
this young woman who adopted herself
thumbs up sister did a simultaneous
protest against the city government for
his lack of transparency
about the decision-making process that
led to the creation
of such a wasteful project so in the
name of safeguarding public interest
and in pursuit of governmental
accountability she demanded
that the city government make available
a crucial document
that underwrote the night illumination
project
her petition for a copy of that document
uh
hit the stone wall uh it was like
they were passing the buck from one
office to the next and never gave her a
response
so she was feeling very frustrated she
then turned to weibo
to recruit 1 000 netizens willing to
post
their thumbs up photos now thumbs up
really is a satirical play signifying
just the opposite
thumbs down while waiting for the
the the responding post to trickle in
uh this feisty young woman uh raised the
stakes
by bringing two special presents gifts
to the city to the city hall to further
embarrass the authorities what did she
bring
she brought a jumbo white pear now in
chinese
this kind of pear is pronounced as yali
which is homophonous to another chinese
word
pressure the other so she was actually
bringing the
more pressure to the city hall the other
present she brought
to the city officials it was a plastic
ball
shaped like a porcupine alluding to the
government's antics
of passing citizen petitions like hot
potatoes from court to court
so hundreds of thumbs up photos turned
up
under the hashtag thumbs up sister
of delivering the facetious message to
targeted officials
the tactic that she resorted to was
bao and bien they mean by fake prison
which is a form of indirect sanction
familiar to the chinese schooled in the
politics of sarcasm for thousands of
years
the playful weibo fans understood her
strategy instantaneously
so a small sensation was created online
and not surprisingly
this feisty young woman got finally got
a face-to-face interview with the city
officials
my next example is a lgbtq
example when iceland's prime minister
johanna and his and her lesbian lover
were paying a state visit to china
this ngo supporter for gay love
strategized ways of using social media
to
promote social acceptance of
homosexuality
now during and after the state visit
her wife was nowhere to be seen in
mainstream media because she was removed
predictably from all media reports
so the ngo founder spread the news
through a blog post which cena.com the
host
publisher featured on its home page
for several days and you can imagine
this blog
was an instantaneous attention grabber
with a click rate of more than 600 uh
i'm sorry 800 000 times
within a few days it kicked off a
tongue-in-cheek
campaign slogan let's search for the
prime minister's
harmonized wife okay so
my next example is free lunch for
children which is a very famous weibo
campaign
launched by uh dongfae uh
he's a free agent a journalist he
discovered that [ __ ] joe province lacked
canteens so he launched a crowdfunding
campaign on weibo
a free lunch for children he
successfully mobilized the millions
hundreds of millions of chinese netizens
to participate in the campaign by
donating one yen
he then used the funds raised to feed
more than 80
000 children per day in more than 300
schools
spread over central and western parts of
china
now most significantly the network
effect of that campaign
forced the chinese government to respond
in kind in 2012 china's state council
rolled out the policy which allocated 16
billion um per year to improve
the nutrition of rural students by early
2015
32 million children in 1300 counties
have benefited from the governmental
subsidy program
this case shows how charity
can actually lead to successful advocacy
why call this a shadow advocacy because
neither don fey nor his
weibo supporters were consciously
engaged in policy advocacy
um all right well other people may also
say
this is a case of uh ryan
human c military tactics uh the
messaging goes like this
uh chinese style okay beware the crowd
has spoken
can the government please pay attention
okay so my final example is an
environmental activism example
the arrival of social media platforms
have made
environmental advocacy easier and more
efficient
and faster now since 2009 there has been
a proliferating number of
air monitoring soil monitoring
metal water testing campaigns
galvanizing citizen participation
the example i wanted to share is green
beagle
the ngo launched a pm 2.0
air monitoring campaign and they loaned
portable air monitors to local residents
who then report who then reported their
testing results on weibo green beagle
also integrated a crowdfunding campaign
initiative into their multi-city
advocacy campaign
simply put their goal was to mobilize 1
000 donors per city
requesting a minimum of 25 yen per
person to purchase air monitoring
equipment
for each city now beijing shanghai
guangzhou and wenzhou have all reached
the goal
uh true to the spirit of web 2.0 the
original beijing-based
movement was decentralized and
and spread over into multiple local
campaigns
with the netizens all over china
responding to the call
by setting up their own city named
weibo hashtag for example wuhan pm 2.0
to a 2.5 air monitoring or shanghai pm
2.5
they are monitoring and so on
so all those campaigns
were created with the purpose of
bringing incremental change
by now it should be obvious that there
are many activists in china
and they are making social change in
measured
non-contentious and measured steps
scholars in china and the other parts of
the world have been debating over
the vice and virtue of slacktivism
or fingertip philanthropy
those terms are derogatory descriptions
of
casual random acts such as taking a
snapshot of polluted river or sending a
virtual leaf to create a virtual tree
as opposed to engaging in sustained
environmental activism
and longer term systemic operations
of actions on the ground as an activist
myself
and a practitioner of both online and
offline
activism i support the argument
that twitter and other social media
platforms
have enabled activists to create new
communities
and spread their social courses to a
wider public
i also believe that the small acts can
add up
and can trigger qualitative change over
time
so why do activists have to choose
between
online and offline action and why do we
as researchers have to arbitrate which
which form is superior
to the other well we have another saying
that runs parallel to
all roads lead to rome the saying goes
all rivers find their ways to the ocean
so the ocean of compassion does not
discriminate against small streams or
drops of dew
okay now we come to the final
topic on my menu future village which is
a
a designed for good project
that i launched last summer in china
we all knew about uh smart city
paradigms
right which is a top-down
investment-driven
and governmental-sponsored project that
gives
a digital facelift to big cities
ngo 2.0 is interested in helping out
villages not
cities we are committed to energizing
grassroots network and reviving
grassroots culture and we are
naturally drawn to methods built on
grassroots mobilization
in a nutshell the future village is
driven by three horses
designed for good tactful good and
poverty alleviation
the future program the future village
program was inspired by the mit fab lab
model
as some of you may know the fablab model
emphasizes
the making of open source hardware
and collaborative design with the
clientele and in this case
our clientele are the villages the
fablab model demonstrates how
an underserved community can be powered
by technology and other means
at the grassroots level so how do we go
about this
program uh after we identify
a future village candidate we first
asked
the villagers to identify and to
articulate a collective need
we then mobilize researchers and
practitioners from different sectors
to run a civic uh to run a civic
hackathon
as the first step and i emphasize
this is the first step of building trust
and the working relationship
with the villagers here is a
working definition of this first step
of the future village through hackathons
we bring together makers and package
software developers researchers from
materials science
architecture bioecology design thinking
public art
art practitioners and more and the
participants include the villagers
university teachers and students high
school
students programmers designers engineers
artists etc and jointly we designed a
vision
for future village we have implemented
this program in four
villages so here i want to share with
you one village
this is a village in the carating desert
in north china
an environmental ngo there contacted us
now in china the most conventional way
of greening the desert
is to drop the seed bombs into the
desert and then leave
the siblings there to survive by
themselves
which as you can imagine is not a very
effective method of greening the desert
so this ngo instead of planting trees in
the desert
they hand in a sandy area
and build a fence around it to ward off
intruding animals including humans to
let
the land uh recover by itself
their experiment was very successful as
you can tell
by looking at the satellite image did
you see the square
uh square that has turned green that was
their
uh first experiment but very
few people knew about what they were
doing so they came to us
they came to ngo 2.0 with a
communication need they wanted more
people to know about their unique method
of cleaning the desert so we ran a
hackathon for them
we the hackathon produced four solutions
and i'm going to
share three solutions with you the first
solution now the first
one team uh resorted to the concept of
earth art
by working with artists to design earth
shapes that look cool we know that
interesting
earth art is communication intensive by
itself
so it would create a very cool satellite
image
better than that the square uh result
that's powerful communication the second
solution is a sound project
we're working with a music artist to
design
ways of collecting sand in the in the in
the windy desert
each season would create yield different
sounds we then treat the sound and sell
the sound bites as ringtones
to help the ngo raise funds and to also
raise public awareness of the village
um our third uh solution is a wechat
game
uh the game starts with a uh
a green a a piece of green land and the
player has to eject
uh animals and humans that were dropped
from above onto the green land and if
the ejection is successful then the
green
expands if it fails and the green
shrinks
all right so those are the solutions
that came out of the hackathon so what
about the next steps
well after the hackathon is done we then
enter the village with
experts high school students university
students
at the regular intervals we're engaging
on site conversation
with uh villagers and the village
leadership to
explore other needs that could be
tackled by our team
and the goal of those regular visits is
to explore
the possibilities of helping
villagers to discover new forces of
production
improve their environment and livelihood
and also
enrich the cultural life of village
children
most of them were left behind children
because their parents
usually go to big cities to to work
to make their ends to make a living
so the cultural life of village children
would like to enrich
the cultural life of village children
through a variety of measures
some of which would involve media
and tech and technology but
not everything we do is technological
because we also involve other other
people
public art practitioners in the program
for example
this is a quick first eye view of our
collaborators
on on the future village program
you can tell by there are three
universities
um two i.t companies a museum and
techie communities i'm sharing the
future village program with you for a
purpose
i wanted to illustrate how ngo 2.0
operates
building multi-sectoral collaboration is
our dna we work with different sectors
to produce social good
and the sectors include not only the ngo
sector but also
the universities i.t companies design
companies
techie communities and so on i shall
call all those social actors
non-confrontational change makers and
together we are building a
decentralized multi-sectoral coalition
that is purposeful but non-contentious
driven by a powerful and spoken
consensus of all the parties involved
to build a federal society
this is the end of my presentation
and i welcome comments and questions
thank you
so if you don't mind i'm i have a
question that i wanted to start off with
okay um and and that is um
you know in some of the examples that
you um
that you described and i'm thinking
specifically of the young woman who
um you know brought the white pair
um in some ways you know you could say
that that
is is confrontational but it's it's not
right um okay and and
um but there you know that young woman
you know must have felt um
like the the the
that the risks were not as high
as um
you know that that there was enough that
she would have
enough of a response a popular response
so that whatever risks involved
might have been okay yeah um you're
minimized right
um and i so i guess my ques
i have a couple of questions that branch
off from that example
and that is um
one you know what in
in terms of your own understanding or
definition of
what counts as confrontational what does
not
what is non-confrontational okay is that
based upon
um just the western ideas
of that you're pushing back against of
of
sort of direct on the you know boots on
the ground
action and then just quickly the second
part of that is
um you know have you seen examples where
um where the
where individuals or ngos have
engaged in what might have felt like or
seemed like
non-con confrontational activism um in
the way that you're describing it
but the state saw that as crossing a
certain line
right and pushed back yeah sure this is
a very good question because
it allows me to talk about several
things that i didn't have
time to address my talk first of all
uh the the
thumbs up sister and the guy who shaved
his head
they live in guangzhou now
locale is very important uh china
is not a homogeneous entity uh
guangzhou is known to be one of the most
um
uh liberal uh one of one of the most
open-minded
and the liberal city uh in china
and also okay uh uh
so here i can i can share with you our
experience
in the uh in 2010 and 2011.
we did uh um we did
two um literacy so social media literacy
training workshops one
mainland and one in angry and
we we had a very bad time because we
were pursued by
public security officers in those
provinces
so this is something fascinating about
china because
it uh well
every locale has a different definition
of what is tolerable
what is tolerable what is what is the
boundary
right um every locale sort of
uh is a sinai autonomous in deciding on
what is allowed to take place
within my province so
after 2010 after those two bad exa
experiences i made a decision in 2011 to
hold
a workshop in beijing right under the
nose of the emperor
and i my logic went that if they didn't
if the center
if the central uh government didn't like
what i'm doing then
just shut me down i would i don't want
to
play the uh the cat and and
and mice game with the local with the
local governments
so this is one thing guangzhou is very
liberal
that allowed them to do what they did i
don't think what they did would be
tolerated in vietnam for example
or in beijing
the other thing i wanted to point out is
that the
guidelines for censorship is not what we
thought
uh in the west the chinese censors
do not necessarily disallow individual
descent what they care about is to
prevent
individual descent from escalating into
a collective action
against the government so uh
to uh to a certain extent individual
descent is allowed
it is because of the discrepancies of
locale
uh it allows activists to navigate
so if i couldn't do something beijing i
i can do it in uh
in jiangsu province or other places
all right
thanks
yes hi
thank you so much for your talk i was
wondering what
themes or cases have you noticed that
get more
like positive responses uh
in activism and also how to cope with
the
i guess like pro-government bots who
might want to
obstaclize um the collective action
online like uh yeah i didn't get the
second part of the
like how to cope with the government
bots online
but like yeah like b-o-t-s
uh ops like the fake
profiles that might want to um
like prohibit you know like these like
actions online
okay all right uh um um
first question um uh
what kind of uh uh ngo issue areas
that are more acceptable right to the to
the government
um well many chinese ngos create
state-sanctioned nonprofit programs for
example
providing educational assistance to
children living in poor family
in poor families in rural and urban
china
or providing social welfare to
the elderly and the the other friend
dis-franchise groups and so on i didn't
quite understand the second
question so could somebody maybe
help rephrasing the question
emily uh i another word i think
you might be reaching for ambar is um
moderators
like how do moderators work on online
chinese forums um
to censor what people say oh they they
have a list
of tabooed terms and concepts
uh uh internally the every social media
platform
hired those officers
to monitor the posts so they have a list
yes and uh
more or less but how how an activist
could like try to
keep your own like campaign uh without
you know like getting like sensor okay
oh yeah sure okay there are there are
different strategies
okay there are different strategies so
one strategy
is to um to
to make incremental change which is
crucial you know
a measured step-by-step change agenda
alleviates the anxieties of the state so
that's
the rules of the thumb first one second
it has to do how you position yourself
for example in geo 2.0
i could have positioned ngo 2.0 as
a media focused ngo
but media is too sensitive so instead i
position ourselves as a technology
driven
ngo i very rarely use the word media
in china the other uh
strategy would be resorting to
the to the tactics of camouflage
uh strategic hiding uh or systemic
mimicry aimed at
facing one's own presence from the
photographic media of surveillance
uh and there are many examples of of
of camouflage the other uh a very
very popular method of coping with
sensors
is to resort to the rhetoric
of the powerful to curb the exercise of
power
what i meant is legitimately
legitimizing and framing your contention
by employing state laws official policy
discourse state propaganda governmental
commitments
to hamstring concerned party elites
for support and for collaboration
in more concrete terms let me give you
an example about
organizations run by tibetans
and muslims in china they typically
frame their mission
as cultural perseverance rather than the
promotion of religious diversity
and take and take uh uh
hiv aids organizations they typically
frame uh resort to public health uh
approach rather than dwelling on the
issues of human rights so there are many
many ways to
walk around the obstacles but
incrementalism is what everybody sort of
resorts to i'm very happy that i
am in the u.s because that sort of
prevented us from making jumps and
leaves in our activities
which is good for us
uh the other thing uh the other thing is
that one has to
have a low profile so for the first five
years uh
during the ngo 2.0 while i was running
ngo 2.0 i rejected all interviews
uh by media because we were too weak
at that time at the beginning and i
didn't want to be identified
so it was not until after 2014 after we
were officially registered as
an npo that i began to talk to
journalists in china
i think both eric and diego had
hands up um
but i didn't see who raised their hands
first
okay i guess i guess i can go
thank you for hi for your presentation
uh
i really love the reference to james
scott's work
i think it was really good uh
so but i have a question probably
related to
uh professor paul's uh question
about like northwestern and western this
kind of like differentiation
uh i was thinking about the this
opposition
uh because there is also sometimes where
actions that that seek social change in
northwestern context
take a confrontational stance right
especially like i'm thinking in the
context of latin america probably not in
china right
uh there are sometimes like collectibles
or friends that occupy certain terrains
and
suddenly build a village or
a because they are fighting for housing
rights
um and this obviously breaks the rule of
law right as we understand it
that means like kind of like western
civic context right
so i know your work is focused on china
specifically but i i guess my
my my question would be uh how
how if we can think about like
activism from a global perspective uh
taking not into account so much binaries
between no western and western
perspective but
more like a gradient or a more nuanced
view of
what is like actually confrontational
probably not so confrontational uh
strategies from activism
um uh do you mind uh
rephrasing your question yeah yeah for
sure i i'm thinking if we can like
probably surpass binaries conceptions
but binary conceptions of activism
between western and
western and think more about probably
a nuanced view of like probably
something is more confrontational that
other
and not so much assignment
a non-confrontational or confrontational
yeah there is a well as i said earlier
there is a continuum
of situations so there are different
great uh
there are different shades of gray right
[Music]
so i i i i actually
don't know how to uh how to
um how to
respond to your question um except that
um
that
uh that they
that that it is well the questions
is really really i think big
right even though it varies from regime
to regime but
but it is there and
one you know i think uh one has to as
well as an
activist you always try to walk the fine
line
between uh or in authoritarian countries
you walk a fine line between compliance
and self-empowerment which is not an
intuitive exercise
so yeah well uh well in china now it's
quite impossible to openly challenge
the chinese government and i think hong
kong the hong kong protest
serves as a good example
that um well that
the hong kong situation i think calls
for uh
a an entirely different uh
response than what i uh talked about uh
yeah uh what what do you think i mean
what uh
since i'm not sure i completely
understood your question and
i would like to get a sense of how you
uh approach your own question
uh well so i i guess
there is like uh there are
there are not necessarily a
correspondence between like
non-confrontational and non-western
activism but probably not in
northwestern context you can have
confrontational digits and so
i i i i guess i i
i'm i'm trying to complicate the issue
of like not necessarily
approaching certain contexts with a
certain
framing of how activists should be in
this context
well you know non-confrontationalism is
just a
term that incorporates all kinds of
approaches
right um
eric would you like to go next and then
it looks like and then emily
great thanks and thanks for the really
interesting talk
i have a number of questions but i'm
going to keep it to one
um i'm specifically interested in what
you
talked about um the kind of
multi-sectoral collaboration
um that you talked about at the end and
um and my question comes from uh work
that i'm actually doing in eastern
europe around the same
this the same concept and trying to
understand
um ways in which um you know groups from
multiple sectors can effectively
collaborate towards common cause
um in in in the eastern european context
there is government involved i imagine
that in um in the chinese context
government is not one of the sectors uh
that is that is involved
but what i'm interested in is um and i
know the difficulty in this work is
aligning the incentives of the different
the different players and so i'm curious
if you can talk a little bit about
how sure how you've how you've addressed
that how you work to align those
incentives to achieve your goals
all right thank you eric first of all i
want to say that mit is a powerful brand
name
which allowed me to really quickly
round up collaborators it took me like a
couple of months
to set up ngo 2.0 in 2008
and i think asian people
including the chinese uh really worship
uh a a university like my mit
i i remember once uh writing in a taxi
in beijing
and uh got into a conversation with the
taxi cab driver and he asked me
he he knew that i was not local because
i just didn't look like a local
beijinger
so i told him that i'm a professor and
he said oh you know
he thought it was chinese professor but
then i said
mit he went like oh my god mit
can i have a photo with you so that kind
of
um uh um uh positive uh
uh response to mit so the brand name
helped a great deal uh the mit brand
name
helped me round up techies
and the universities it is effortless
for me to
set up to set up
collaborative ties with chinese
universities
i think always the challenge is
it's easier to invite collaborators but
it's difficult to let them go
so now i'm getting very cautious about
inviting people to join
incentives um
the those people okay the social secting
china is a rather small sector
everybody knew each other sort of so if
you identified
one collaborator they you will be led to
the others
we work with it corporations
we really don't work with the i.t
companies themselves we work with
the volunteers within the id company
they are techies they are programmers or
they are
hardware makers
um so
um i guess well did i did i
uh um did i uh answer
some of your questions or no do you want
to
sort of uh yeah keep keep uh keep asking
if i
didn't uh give you a a full answer
uh you uh well i can follow up with you
later i know we're almost out of time so
i'll let other people ask questions i
know there's other
other questions all right thank you
thomas um
so i'm interested in the in the role of
funding so i know that
a very a common um liberal regime
used to constrain the role of ngos is to
not allow them to receive external
funding or to yeah to find a way to
um indirectly restrain them in that
sense and i was wondering
um yeah in your work house has this
resulted
in in bringing funding probably from the
us right
and how do chinese ngos work with that
okay so funding kept me
kept me awake at night actually since i
started
ngo 2.0 my insomnia got worse
i have to pay for my employees right
we were funded by four at the beginning
for 10 years actually they continued to
fund us
and because of their funding we were
sort of uh
suspect right in the eyes of
the public security officers and also in
the eyes of other collaborators
before we got registered in 2014 it was
difficult for us to really
attract funding in china
but i do not want to get more funding
from the us
because it would make us look even more
dangerous
right so
um i was able to uh
again use my mit uh
the logo mit logo to
attract funding from um
from companies like a financial company
actually they funded
us to develop our crowd source
philanthropy map
um we my goal is to diversify
our funding so that we would not be
left in the code if one funder walked
away
fourth one we had a very difficult year
in 2008 because the chinese government
clamped down
on foreign ngos meaning fourth
foundation
was monitored and they uh for the whole
year
i we did not have any funding and
it was a very difficult year but now
things got better uh fourth foundation
i think past the past another hurdle and
they're fine they they are
under the jurisdiction of the u.s china
friendship
association and they continue to fund us
but they are not the only funders so we
are in a better situation
uh did i answer your question thomas
perfectly
thank you you're welcome
emily and then um we have a uh
question from the attendee q a after
emily
sure okay thank you very much for
speaking to us today
uh i have a question about um the people
who are leading these movements
to create incremental sorry inc
uh like the woman whose um photo you
showed who brought that pair to the like
city
building and then the young man who
shaved his head
um i'm wondering whether
um there's a certain threshold beyond
which if they lead too many movements
they become kind of a person of interest
and
can't really continue to try to create
change in different ways
and then also how that varies by by
region
i imagine it might based on what you
were talking about earlier
and then also by their um
kind of um like
level of awareness or level of um well
like high prof high profileness like if
you are
um you know at for example your level
versus someone who's
just a young person in a in a city um
whether your relative sort of
um command of power might affect your
ability to continue to create an
incremental change across different
movements and sorry that was really
convoluted so let me know if i should
actually i will i will address your
question if i
if i didn't give you a satisfactory
answer you can always uh
follow up with another question so yeah
uh i would imagine that uh
that the thumbs up sister will not do
another weibo campaign right because
then she would be inviting
uh the spotlight which is not good that
explains why i have stayed low uh
i had i have kept a low profile until
2015 because i do not want to
incrementalism is about anonymity so
why are you going to why why do you want
to attract
the media attention to you in chinese we
have another saying
um a pig is afraid of being
fat because that would be the time for
the
for the pig to be slaughtered so
um so so so that uh yeah
um you you're supposed to keep a low
profile um
and i don't think she will uh keep
uh protesting uh or
at uh on another occasion it would be
very dangerous but
he uh he has been working with an ngo in
guangzhou
all the time so he's fine
uh what are the other i think you
probably brought up another question but
i
i think i i lost my focus
[Music]
uh uh i mean that was very helpful
yeah now did you have another question
that i haven't uh addressed
i think you you covered it thank you all
right great thank you
well i have a um a question from jamie
dereza
uh in the q a um who
asks or about culture specifically
um and uh
here's the question um i was wondering
about non-confrontational activism in
the art scene
especially in underground spaces music
cinema literature etc
uh two things one their modes of
production
and distribution and second how does
your argument regarding the paradox of
invisibility under the light hold for
that scene
do you mind pasting that question onto
the chat box
sure i can look at it
second
well you may be able to see it actually
oh okay here we go okay all right
oh
um in the art scene uh would you say
that the
uh the earth art example i think that
that is an example of
of of non-confrontational activism
and how does the organ regardless
well you see the thing about
non-confrontationalism is that you
shouldn't be afraid
of being exposed because it is
non-confrontational
does that make sense
is well let me why don't i follow up on
that a little bit and
is there a um yeah is there a vibrant
kind of
underground music scene for example
where um
both in terms of lyrically and in terms
of the kind of spaces
that young people are uh building
um you know do those also become spaces
that are under this rubric of
non-confrontational activities well
listen the album uh
the company the music company would not
will not release a song or an album
that is considered uh problematic
so and also you know i i think uh in
china it's not just the censorship
imposed on uh practitioners
but internal censorship you internalize
the uh you internalize uh
as a citizen you internalize
things that you think might create a
stir
or invite the unnecessary
attention from the public from the state
or from the public
so i would i would say
china relies more on
this kind of internal censorship inner
policing
inner policing than external censorship
but to answer your question quickly
no art new music that is made public
will be will be problematic because
they're already filtered there's already
a filtering system that screened out
the the the the so-called dangerous
or politically incorrect messaging
but uh there's one thing that i think
you all need to know
is that the sensors are not like they're
not like devils uh they
they communicate with you if they spot
something problematic
like with us we were approached by
by sensors sometimes you know they
didn't understand why we were doing this
so they came to us they said
can we have a conversation you know i
have a question about this so you
explain it to them
uh another example i had was years ago i
had an
article published i wanted to seek a
publisher
in uh in china and eventually i got that
piece published
in beijing not in shanghai contrary to
your intuitive
perception beijing is a
uh is a place that has more free room to
for us to navigate than shanghai because
there are two governments in beijing
there's a central government there is
the municipal government
so you if you uh if you lost the favor
with one with the father you could go to
your grandfather
and you get your things done uh so
i that article had a few words that
sort of hit the button hit the
hit the flag uh so i got an
email one day from the publisher saying
hey professor wang
this article is great we'd like to
publish that but there are
a few words i would wonder if you would
consider revising what you would
consider replacing
so to my big surprise one word that they
singled out
was capitalism i was like
what on earth you know capitalism so i
replaced that word with the commodity
economy so they communicated with you
if an ngo is in trouble you will get a
call
from the local government and the
the eu phenom the euphemism is
you will be invited out to have tea
you're invited out of t mini the sensor
wants to talk to you so you sit down and
you
sort things out and you make some
adjustment
uh communication dialogues
is crucial for ngos to operate
smoothly something that the hong kong
protesters
didn't do or didn't want to do which was
really sad um okay
okay i think we're just coming up on 6
30 um
so i just wanted to thank you
sincerely um for for this really rich
talk and and discussion
and thank all of you who attended